so in this channel we talk an awful lot
about how to run faster punch harder
lift heavier come up with more awesome
creative ideas unfortunately the reality
is that for the most part you're not
going to have to use most these skills
gone are the days when we'd be
challenged to a samurai sword fight in
the street
unfortunately I mean fortunately
unfortunately instead these days most of
our success comes down more to soft
skills things like persuasion charisma
emotional iCube sensitivity these are
the things that allow us to get on with
other people to persuade people to buy
into our ideas to climb the corporate
ladder and that's what's going to
determine whether you're highly
successful or whether you're kind of
stuck in a rut so I'm starting a video
series looking at more of these kind of
soft skills and psychological warfare so
we can see how to manipulate people into
doing our bidding or you know something
less crazy and then if that doesn't work
then you can go and watch on the grants
videos and learn how to kick their ass
ok so we're going to start with
negotiation to get the outcome that you
want in some kind of debate or
discussion so the obvious example of
using negotiation would be trying to get
a raise or perhaps trying to increase
your rates if you're a self-employed
individual with your clients however
there are many other scenarios where
you're going to find yourself
negotiating whether that means
negotiating in relationships coming to
some kind of compromise or whether it
means talking someone out of a hostage
situation
another very likely situation that I
often find myself in the first thing we
need to do is to identify what our ideal
outcome is what we're trying to achieve
with any negotiation and contrary to
popular belief apart from in that
hostage scenario normally negotiation is
about coming to a satisfying compromise
where both parties are happy with the
outcome where both parties are receiving
value or at least they believe they are
this not only prevents you from souring
that individual on doing future business
with you but it's also more likely to be
successful for both of you
it's much easier to convince someone to
do something that also benefits them
than it is to convince them to do
something that completely does not
benefit them so going into a negotiation
we first need to identify what would
make us both happy
that's called the Zopa or the zone of
possible agreement so if you're trying
to increase the salary and get a raise
and that's going to be the range between
the lowest that you're willing to accept
and the maximum that they're willing to
pay and in most negotiations the outcome
is going to be a compromise somewhere in
the middle there obviously the closer it
is to your end the higher end the more
successful you've been in that
negotiation in fact one technique used
in negotiations often is the napkin
technique here you both write down what
your accept law ideal outcome would be
you write down what you'd be willing to
accept they write down what they'd be
willing to pay and then that gives you
your Zopa and you can work from there
doing a little bit of research before
you go into a negotiation then can be
really beneficial because it allows you
to get a good idea of what's realistic
of what they're likely to accept this
might be asking other people that work
for this organization or individual how
much they get paid or it might mean
benchmarking by looking at what other
people who do your kind of work get paid
this is an example of persuasion it's
the preparation you do before a
negotiation to put the odds in your
favor and there's lots of things you can
do to accomplish this one of the key
things is just timing if you're working
for an organization that's really
struggling they're doing lots of layoffs
and you've just had a disciplinary
hearing then asking for a raise is
unlikely to be successful however if you
just closed the massive deal and if you
know that your organization is just
about to take on another huge client
where you're going to be instrumental
then that's a great time to ask for a
raise well likewise if you're
negotiating with your other half and
she's just come home from work or he's
just come home from work and he's angry
and harassed now's not a good time to
tell them that you want to change your
routine or you want to fix your budget
or go on a big holiday whatever wait
until you're both in a good place in a
good mood and then you're gonna be
you're more likely to get the outcome
that you want sounds really obvious a
lot of people forget to do this you can
also prime this person and get them to
be in a good mood and in particular you
can get in to be in a good mood with you
so one way you might do this for
instance is to if you've got a boss ask
them hope in performing lately ask them
what you've done well they'll then write
back I'm assuming you're going to do
this by email and say here's what you've
been doing really well and yes we're
very satisfied with your performance now
you asked for a raise
you've just asked them to think about
all the
done really well you've got them to tell
you you're doing really well it's now
gonna be much easier for them to agree
to give you a raise a because they're in
good mood with you because they've been
focusing on all your good points and B
because it's very hard for them to come
up with a good reason not to give you a
raise after they've just told you how
good you are likewise you can prime
people by putting them in a good mood by
giving them a nice cup of tea before you
begin your discussion or buying a nice
piece of cake
don't make this obvious they make it
look like bribery instead the aim is
just to make them feel comfortable put
them in a good mood because then they're
more likely to be agreeable
in fact some sales people actually use
oxytocin spray in order to biohack other
people into becoming more agreeable now
not suggesting that you do that but of
course you can get people to be more
agreeable through the use of body
language and building rapport or even
through lighting and music and I'll talk
more about body language in a future
video similar example to this is to use
the power of reciprocity because
basically when you give someone
something or when someone does you a
favor
it creates a powerful urge to
reciprocate by doing the same back in
fact it's human nature to don't want to
do significantly more back for the other
person because their gesture to you
seems to have more value because it came
out of thin air whereas yours is
reciprocation therefore in order to be
seen as equally generous you actually
have to do more and you feel
uncomfortable until you do so so if
someone does something for you
then you're much more likely to then
agree to them or let them get the upper
hand in a subsequent negotiation and you
see this a lot in Europe and in the
Middle East during haggling if you ever
try and buy something from a store
they'll often give your kid or your
sibling a free item of inexpensive
jewelry or a fun gift and that way
you're now feeling in their debt and
you're more likely to be willing to buy
something from them for slightly more
than you might even perceive it as being
worth likewise they might offer you a
cup of tea believe it or not you can be
willing to spend 10 20 30 percent more
just because someone gave you a really
cheap cup of tea a similar concept to
something called anchoring and here
you're going to try and get the other
person to think about a specific amount
of specific outcome that you want so the
example I was given is that if you go
into a meeting where you're being told
why you
can't have 40k a year as your annual
salary it's very likely that you're
gonna walk out of that meeting with 40k
because that's what everyone's focusing
on that's the number we're all talking
about everything that anchored around
that meant that number it's very hard to
get away from it ensuring the
negotiation if they say no to your
original suggestion the original amount
that you want then you need to try and
find a compromise that you're both going
to be happy with often then it's a good
idea to have a target amount that you
want to achieve and then a minimum
amount that you've falled back to
because that will then be much easier to
get and the example I was told is that
of a Girl Scout selling cookies and she
might go door-to-door and say hi mister
or missus will you please buy ten boxes
of cookies it's for a good cause and you
know I've been doing this all day and I
haven't sold many cookies and then the
person at the door will say I'm really
sorry 10 is too much and then she says
well how about just buy one and of
course that seems like a great
compromise a win-win situation which is
what we're trying to achieve remember
they get to feel good she gets money and
it's worked well because she's had a
backup option this also allows us to use
something called contrast from
psychology contrast means of course that
you're offering two contrasting options
where one makes the other seem more
extremely cheap or affordable so say you
go to a shop and you see a tie and it's
a luxury premium tie made from silk the
costs a hundred dollars and then next to
it is the everyday tie for $50 now $50
is still an awful lot of money for a tie
but because it's next to a tie that's
$100 it suddenly seems like quite a good
deal for a tie another good thing to do
is to try and demonstrate how you're
offering the value that you're asking
for and if you're self-employed like me
the way we do that is by saying I'm
having to put my rates but don't worry
because I'm going to offer this extra
value so as a writer I might say I'll do
an extra proofread or I'll do better
formatting and as a result and haven't
put it up just this small amount
everyone wins
another way to do this is by asking for
less by having more negotiations where
you are less ambitious and this way you
can move up in small increments so
Milgram's study of obedience showed how
you could get regular individuals to
deliver fatal electric shocks to
strangers simply by increasing the
amount from
Tilly's this is possible partly because
the researchers wearing lab coats thus
creating a sense of authority but also
because the amount the increments were
so small that it didn't seem like
anything delivering 100 volt shock
doesn't seem like that much when you've
just delivered a 95 volt shock what's an
extra 5 volts gonna do the same thing
goes with asking for a raise or asking
for more money you can slightly increase
the amount as a writer I'll sometimes
say can I have an extra point 1 of a
cent per word which seems like nothing
so of course people will agree but then
they don't realize that that amounts
sometimes to thousands of dollars over
the course of the year of course it
works well here if you break it down
into the smallest units if you've done
all this and the person is still saying
no then you want to look at the way that
they word something so let's say for
instance that you're trying to convince
someone to change something about a
product that you're building together
you've asked and asked and they've said
I'm sorry I've run this by my manager
and I don't think that they're going to
want to change their mind you then look
at what they've actually said and look
for weak points and look for
opportunities to continue that
conversation and don't let it be shut
down because they've actually said eh
they don't think so they don't know and
be they've demonstrated that they don't
have the final say so you can now say in
that case could I please speak with your
manager and put forwards my point of
view or you could say well could you
just run it by them anyways because I'd
really like to find out this is the
great example of where being more
willing to be socially awkward can help
you to get the outcome you want this is
what we often perceive us on being an
alpha male or type-a personality the
willingness to trample on toes and to
make other people feel slightly
uncomfortable there's a kind of social
contract where when someone says that
you know they really mean no but if you
take advantage of their politeness
because most people don't want to just
outright say no if you take advantage of
that and push further they'll often
relent because they've left themselves
no opportunity they haven't completely
shut down that conversation this isn't
gonna win you any friends it's not a
popular strategy however it will very
often get you the outcome that you want
of course speaking of willingness to be
awkward and to break those social
contracts one of the classic techniques
to you
in a negotiation is silence my mum who
worked in telesales told me that the
first to speak would very often be the
loser in any negotiation we have this
natural urge to want to fill a silence
because we find it awkward that's when
we start babbling this often when we say
well you know maybe I could get you a
little bit more money off so don't give
in to that urge use silences to your
advantage and you also come across as
much more confident and they will be
trying to impress you rather than the
other way around
see awkward isn't it in short do you
want them to be agreeable but you want
to be not agreeable and be willing to be
an awkward dick and at the same time be
willing to walk away if you're willing
to walk away if you're in a stronger
position then that often gives you the
upper hand in negotiation if you're
someone who finds it really hard to be
awkward or rude if you're naturally a
people pleaser I am then I recommend you
watch my video on CBT and employ some of
those techniques such as the hypothesis
testing and the thought analysis this
will help you to overcome that urge and
to be awkward when you need to be I will
also say though of course that you
should not misuse these skills once
you've gained the ability to be alpha
because you know no one likes a dick and
if you keep doing this kind of thing
then people aren't gonna want to work
with you only use it when it really is
something important to you that you
really need to win because ultimately
the very best way to get raises to get
your way and to make people agreeable
with you is just to be a good person and
I actually believe that big business is
normally ethical business if you provide
a good service if you're loyal if you're
honest if you're on time then for all
the fun and the bombast of this video
that's actually the best way to get
raised to get loyalty from your
customers and to get friends who will
let you win the occasional argument most
of my razors have come simply because I
hand in my work on time and I try really
hard and smiling gets you a long way too
finally if after all this negotiation
the person still says no then don't see
this as a loss citizen opportunity so if
you're going for raise we're using that
again and they say no I'm really sorry
you can't have the raise then you just
say that's fine this is once you've
tried every other option you say that's
fine can I please have some feedback and
can you please let me know why I'd need
to do in order to be worth that race to
you how could I make myself worth that
extra 2 grand a year
what else could I achieve and by doing
this a you get useful feedback and B
they then tell you the criteria you need
to fulfill in order to get that raise if
you then go away and you work on those
things and you make sure to fulfill them
and then you come back and renegotiate
well that's gonna be very difficult for
them to say no because you've done
exactly what they've asked you've almost
got a verbal contract there's gonna
result in you getting the outcome you
want likewise if you were negotiating
with friends about where to go on
holiday and they don't let you win you
end up going where they want you just
say then well in that case what's the
compromise for next time next time how
are you going to make up for this fact
that I've lost out so there you go guys
I hope you found this useful and
interesting you can use this in business
if you're self-employed you can use it
along with my gig economy advice or you
can use it in your line of work and like
I say it also works in relationships
always think about the best way to
approach any discussion in order to get
the outcome that you want in future I've
said in the past that I'm going to talk
about body language
likewise about persuasion and other
aspects of psychological warfare so if
you think that sounds interesting
then thanks a ton for watching subscribe
down below and I'll see you next time
bye for now